[Musique]
m dos elle dans notre maloya c'est le
nom du projet porté par l'association la
ram la réunion des arts et musique dans
le cadre de la résidence d'artistes qui
s'est tenue au musée du sel à saint leu
ce samedi 13 août a eu lieu la
restitution du travail fait avec les
jeunes et les moins jeunes pendant les
ateliers depuis janvier en remettant
donc en valeur ce patrimoine qui le
musée du sel le département fait une
pierre deux coups puisqu'il consacre
aussi ce musée du sel à résidence donc
d'arte 6 donc c'est intéressant dans le
sens qu'on va jouer la proximité donc
des gens viennent ici pour échanger un
pour partager pour échanger et c'est des
publics de tous de tous âges de toutes
horizons donc ils sont dans une dans une
situation je dirais de production de
production notamment autour de la langue
créole et c'est l'âme réunionnaise qui
présente ici ce soir ces projets était
partie des neuf retenu pour la cinquième
édition des résidences patrimoine et
création mise en place par le
département dans le but est de financer
un processus créatif mettant en valeur
le patrimoine de la réunion
ce projet il a été sélectionné deux
raisons d'abord à lille
vraiment écho à la nouvelle expression
du lait fpsl ses racines go les scènes
de l'océan indien où on propose donc un
parcours scénographique sur les salines
l'audience le projet de l'arabe et qui a
été sélectionné pour natal pour notre
résidence justement se proposait de
proposer un voyage musical
dans les îles de l'océan indien ce soir
on a la restitution de ce travail avec
donc des textes qui ont été qui aurait
pris part
l'auteur on a une restitution d'un
atelier percussions là on en plantant
des enfants du couple à l'investiture
musical de l'ensemble de ce travail de
ce voyage à travers les rustres
la restitution s'est voulue
représentative des ateliers proposés
dans le cadre de cette résidence
d'artistes compte jouer en créole
écriture de fond du coeur recueilli dans
un livre atelier percussions un projet
de création artistique imprégné de sel
on s'est greffé un petit peu sur
l'exposition en cours au musée du sel
qui nous a un peu inspiré 7 la version
du sel dans l'océan indien et on s'est
dit qu'on allait prendre une base de
langue créole qui était finalement en
certains points commune à toutes les
îles de l'océan indien partir là dessus
faire des ateliers d'écriture greffier
de la musique donc du maloya est
également à côté faire du théâtre en
l'encré si l'on veut propager la culture
réunionnaise c'est au public jeune qu'il
faut mais j'allais dire s'attaquer non
pas s'attaquer mais en tout cas fort
mais la rame en fait son objectif
principal lors de cette résidence là
c'était gérable en quelque chose que je
dirais la formation à la culture
réunionnaise nos jeunes nos enfants ne
sont pas tous sensibles à culture
réunionnaise et tel était l'objectif de
cette résidence d'artistes pari réussi
grâce à ce projet les jeunes ont pu
approfondir leurs connaissances de la
culture réunionnaise et même pour
certains découvrir la pointe au sel et
son musée pour la première fois
[Musique]